5 54 on your monday morning all right
what's driving you crazy let's really
talk about flashing lights
in school zones you know we had a lot of
questions about why the lights were
flashing in those school zones when kids
were not on campus
well now you've got to get back into the
groove of paying extra attention got a
message for drivers who are
either just passing through and for
anyone dropping off young ones some for
their very first ever in school
experience
safety first slow down
now it shouldn't matter that they're
going to be extra police patrols around
schools with
hefty fines for violations but if that's
what motivates you to do the right thing
then yay
this isn't just for speeders though
mom's dad's grandparents it also could
be you
if you double park or swing u-turns that
are not allowed
also any school that serves as a ccsd
food distribution site will still have
the low speed limit lights flashing at
various times a day in fact
you may see even more schools turning
them on that's because with elementary
schools back
in session those campuses will no longer
be food distribution sites the
district's moving them
to nearby middle junior or senior high
campuses we have a link to all of those
sites on our website 8newsnow.com
thanks for watching out for the kids in
our community
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone if there's something driving
you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com